>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Carla Hayden: Good afternoon.
I hope all of you have enjoyed
meeting one another over lunch
and I've been reading about and
hearing about the great work
that you are all doing
and we are very grateful
that you are doing this work.
And congratulations to our
outstanding 2017 award winners
and best practice honorees.
When I think about the
impact of literacy I have
to quote the great statesman
Frederick Douglas who said,
"Once you learn to read
you will be forever free."
And your work is helping
millions of people free themselves
from the shackles of illiteracy
to achieve the success
that literacy can bring.
And now it is my great
pleasure to introduce the man
who is most responsible
for today's event.
David Rubenstein created the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards
Program five years ago.
And thanks to his generous ongoing
support and belief in the power
of literacy, the library
has awarded nearly one
and a half million dollars in prizes
to 66 institutions in 30 countries.
Please join me in welcoming
Mr. Rubenstein.
>> David Rubenstein: The Library
of Congress Literacy Awards came
about because I had thought that
the Library of Congress in addition
to doing all the wonderful things it
does should be promoting literacy.
Literacy as we all know is a
terrible problem in our country.
Illiteracy rate, depending on
how you look at it is somewhere
between 12 and 13 percent of
adults are functionally illiterate.
And that is a serious
problem, as you all know.
If you are functionally illiterate
your chance of earning a good income
and also having a happy
life is reduced.
Your chance of being part
of our criminal justice
system is increased.
So the idea is to try
to reward people
and acknowledge people
who have done sometime.
We're not going to change all the
illiteracy problems in this country
by having these awards, but
maybe some people will read
about what we're doing and some
people might be more motivated
to do some things to
help illiteracy problems.
I shouldn't say while we don't
address the other problem I'm
worried about which is aliteracy.
It is something is also of concern.
About 30% of people who graduate
from college do not ever read
another book in their life,
which is not a good situation.
But it's sad that so many
people who can read choose not
to read and not to read a book.
And it's a sad situation.
So what we're trying to do today
is just really honor people
who have done great things with
their life in terms of helping
to reduce illiteracy in the
areas they are talking about.
We don't have enough money
to give everybody an award.
We don't have as much money as
we should have to fight the cause
of illiteracy but we are trying
to do something to say the Library
of Congress cares about it
and it's something that all
of you should be proud
for what you're doing.
>> R. Sriram: To summarize,
there are not enough books
in enough languages
and not enough access.
Pratham Books was established in
2004 to address these problems
in India where there are some 300
million children under the age of 14
and where we have 22 official
languages and some 700 smaller ones.
We're one of the largest
children's publishers in India.
And despite having achieved group
readership of some 50 million
in the last 14 years, we are
far from achieving our mission
of putting a book in
every child's hands.
We therefore started to explore
how technology could play a role
in proving access to books
and in creating more
books in more languages.
And this has led us to
a very exciting journey
and has brought us here.
With regard to print books we have
developed over 350 original titles
in 2 0 languages for a
total of 2,500 titles.
We have printed and distributed
14 million books so far,
plus 16 million story cards.
Our price points are
five cents to 60 cents
for a high quality full color books,
a sample of which is available
in the room next door.
Our estimated readership
so far is 50 million and
yet 300 million children
to reach in India alone.
>> Sharon Darling:
So I started thinking
about a more holistic approach
to education and looking
at how do we bring parents
and children together?
How do we get them out of the
[inaudible] that they're in.
And how do we help the parents
get the skills they need
to start feeling good
about themselves?
Because I had taught adults
to read in a church basement
and I knew the stigma that they felt
and the fear of letting
anybody know.
And so how do we get
them to come out?
And how do we get their
children engaged
so that they get an early start
and they don't fall so far behind?
So the only thing I could think
of in the hills and hollers
of Kentucky was to bring them
on a school bus to a school.
And so the three and four year olds
came with their parents, the three
and four year olds were right next
door, the parents go literacy skills
but they started feeling
like they could learn.
And the children were
getting good early childhood.
But they started coming together
as a group of parents to try
to solve problems together.
But what was the magic of it
was that the parents spent
at least an hour working with
their own children everyday.
So they had a chance to see the
early childhood teacher working
with their child.
They had a chance to know what
their child was doing through play
and how they were learning and
what they could do at home.
And most of all they
had a chance to know
that they were important
in their child's life.
Every parent cares
about their child.
So they had an opportunity to
get the skills and the knowledge
that they needed to play with
their children and have fun
with their children and at
the same time help them learn.
>> Joel Zarrow: We have
several design principles
that really provide the
foundation for the work we do.
The first is that teachers
are the solution.
We are not going to increase early
literacy scores at the rate we need
to unless we provide teachers
with the support and expertise
and materials that they need in
order to do their job effectively.
The second is let's focus
on research-based practices
not programs de jour.
So at CLI we take what's called
a balanced literacy approach.
We provide classrooms
with authentic text.
We help teachers learn the
strategies they need to learn
in order to be affective
early literacy instructors.
The third design principle
is partnership.
We don't believe at CLI that what
we do in Chicago can be airlifted
and put down in Houston
and be expected
to have the same kind of impact.
Rather we want to work with our
school or district colleagues.
Understand what their priorities
are, their areas of strengths are,
how they talk about the work,
and support their efforts while
bringing our expertise to the table.
That way we're not this
outsourced early literacy solution.
Rather we're building
capacity within the district,
within the schools, or the
charter management organization
to get the work done.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.